uh my name is guy I go to UCLA I'm in
Delta Top Delta my name is Mateo I go to
UC Santa Barbara I'm a member of Sigma
Alpha Epsilon fraternity my name is
Chris I go to UCLA I'm in Delta Sigma
Phi I'm Max I go to Arizona State
University I'm in Capital Ford hi my
name is Foo I went to Cal State
Fullerton I was in I'm Alexis I'm from
UCSB brother of gamma State Alpha
Fraternity Incorporated just going off
that you guys want to rank each other
[Laughter]
so okay so let's rank first let's do
major and then like your like ideal job
in like 10 years 15 years you want to go
first uh yeah so biochemistry major and
ideally what I want to do is get into
pharmaceutical research
um right now I'm doing gene splicing
with mitochondrial DNA oh that's number
one for me
yeah you wanna you wanna
well I don't understand like half of
what you're talking about you know so
I'm an econ major I have a minor in
Spanish 10 years from now I'd love to go
into arbitration some sort of like
business law I'm a political science and
then I have minors in English and film
and I want to be a like a TV development
executive I want to do business law well
I'm majoring in that now but uh like
definitely uh want to be a lawyer okay
yeah let's go
connections I graduating business
finance but right now I'm doing real
estate in 10 years from now and I'll be
a major real estate Guru here in
California do you have you have your
startup right you're going to be making
IG reels I don't know wait I feel like
the fact that he already has like things
going for him like I kind of want to put
him up there too yeah I'll put you like
two well my startup just a little bounce
house where I ran out like the famous
Bounce House Castle to like sororities
graduation weddings and stuff that's so
much
but I'm a Communications major and then
I wanted to apply psychology and then
minor in education and then I want to
become a teacher
okay well he said he wanted to do law
school too so you you can get up here
all right come over here too so they're
gonna be my lawyer future I hope so what
kind of law are you two trying to get
into uh I want to do uh corporate law
the arbitration so more like for civil
cases like before you go to court you
can like agree on a number you're doing
film I see the camera crew here that's a
lot of work you got to be smart to do
that if you go up there I can go here
shout out who's a little humble he's
about to walk out
I'm just gonna have a switch just
because of all that like expertise that
you have like film political science the
third one yeah English English okay I
kind of want to switch with you just
because I feel like I'm kind of still
like a freshman I would put you like
right here and I'd put myself coming
like smartness and IQ are like two
separate things your smartness or like
whatever you know is like what you're
educated on but your IQ is your
intelligence it means with like your
mind is capable of so like how smart you
are is how you apply your intelligence
so I don't think necessarily like your
major needs to correlate with it because
fair enough like someone's artistic but
like just because they aren't good at
math doesn't mean that they're not smart
and like I think I was just gonna say
like I think IQ is like it's a test that
allegedly tests like your mental
capacity for what though like but for
what and also I think it's like you're
talking about like time management also
like work ethic it's like if you're
talking about intelligence I think
somebody who knows how to like manage
their time and get stuff done is more
intelligent than somebody who has like a
higher capacity but doesn't apply it IQ
has and do with emotional intelligence
and there's also like social
intelligence like you know people were
just really good at like reading a room
and being like hey this is what's going
on I just find it interesting how you
lower yourself because you're a freshman
and he's a senior I feel like the way
you think is I'm like kind of think like
with age comes with like knowledge
because if you really think about it
he's um he graduated already yeah I'm
just
getting honest you don't put yourself at
the end too up here I don't know why you
put yourself back here at the end you
should know you literally one of you
literally said that IQ is like your
ability to apply stuff and we discussed
you already are making money off of
things that you've applied you should be
if not for a second yeah I don't know
and yeah if not for a second fourth yeah
how would you guys Define intelligence
like that's a good question I think like
intelligence is defined as your mind's
capability to like process analyze and
apply information not necessarily in
like a specific field but it could be
like anything like how do I take a new
stuff and how do I utilize that right I
think a big thing with like what makes
somebody intellectual is the fact that
they can admit that they're wrong and
listen to when someone has an opinion
that differs from their own I also think
a huge part of IQ is like creativity
like just thinking of like new ideas
outside of the box like Einstein you
know he like created all these like
different theories that like no one had
ever thought about before and it's like
what was that whole like thing was it
like uh like Isaac Newton invented the
calculus diet version
Isaac Newton objectively smarter than
myself in every regard if you're talking
about like
in like social stuff there's like a lot
of smart people I know that don't know
how to like carry a conversation Isaac
Newton wouldn't get a bid yeah no no he
wouldn't no no bids guy for sure yeah
Mark Zuckerberg literally like just an
NPC probably super smart but like yeah
he's not getting the bid do you guys
feel like there's like a stigma between
like people in fraternity specifically
fraternity men and like intelligence
yeah I feel there is we're always dumb
we just want to drink and party don't do
anything but the reality is we actually
put in a lot of work because we have to
work hard you know to play hard right
and we just don't party we raise money
for charity we always do philanthropy
for the school Frat Boys are definitely
painted as like this two-dimensional
what is it like Wolf of Wall Street
characters
another thing I think like people that
aren't in Greek life don't realize is
like there's like an academic standard
you know like everyone has to like
succeed in the classroom and like get
good grades in order to be an active
member I mean at least for me you're a
college student respectfully I think
that you should be higher up like I
think you should be too I don't know I
just feel like the way that he he's
quieter I think but I think that when he
does speak it's very um deliberate and
like efficient thank you I don't know I
think you're smart like that's smarter
than me at least sure I think like a lot
of the stigma too I think it's on us too
overcome that because I think like
historically it's like you see these
like Barb stool and whatever every time
you see a frat dude he's doing something
dumb and so I think there's like I do
dumb things I feel like I can also do
well in the classroom
um definitely like portrayal in like
movies and stuff too like there's a
really old movie like called Animals
yeah it was just like just a bunch of
like juvenile delinquents living in a
house together somehow making ends meet
and it's like that's not really the
reality of things and like the ward that
it used to like frat and fraternity like
in the news you would never see the full
word fraternity you always see fraps do
that that's got a really bad name and
stigma to that uh
one other question who knows more than
one language
all right I'mma need to raise both of
you this way yeah for sure I would
personally put you out there because I
don't know that's like a big like
lexicon of knowledge I feel like it's
easier when you're raised speaking two
languages I feel like I'm not fluent in
Spanish but I've definitely attempted to
learn it I've definitely attempted to
learn Japanese I'm not fluent in either
but like the fact that I tried like I
don't know right are you watching Animes
in Japanese though yes
oh yeah you should come a little higher
I'd say get back right all right well
pass me past me
you're also really smart okay okay just
like from our conversations I feel like
wrong having Chris last maybe like right
right above me I think yeah
all right do you guys want to change
anything around final ranking
[Music]
hey it's Paulo are you enjoying this
episode of ranking if you are subscribe
down below and like this video now let's
get back to the episode
so you guys have finished the test any
thoughts before you see your scores
it was harder than I thought yeah it was
tough I was getting dizzy at the end
there's so many shapes I'm confused how
some of the things we saw have any like
physical application to like real world
like no it felt like an episode of The
Wiggles like it was bad yeah it was the
Teletubbies it was like the shape system
yeah are you guys ready to know your
scores yeah so in sixth with the lowest
score was Alexis
92 in fifth is Foo
107. a in fourth is Mateo
110.
and third is Max
112.
and second is Kareem
128.
and in first is Chris
141. Daniels so the average score is a
hundred do you think that reflects your
intelligence
um I would say no because it doesn't
calculate in like emotional intelligence
or creativity because the test was
pretty quick it was 35 questions 25
minutes I guess I want a whole bunch
because I was crunching on time I had a
minute left with like eight questions
do you think intelligence immediately
translates to success no by no means no
they're by no I know and luck and
opportunity
when you apply for a job they just can't
what degree you got and then how are you
going to apply to your job and how hard
you're going to work like in business
the most important thing that I see is
how you manage to grow sure each day
what do you think this kind of
experiment says about frat bros we're
smart fellas
you can't put a title on any category of
person we're all smart in different ways
yeah yeah and I think that an arbitrary
number like IQ or GPA is like not the
most like real indicator of that